ونتابع اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور للوصول
الرئيس الصيني شي جي بنج الى موسكو كما
ذكر مراسلنا الى احد مطارات موسكو وتظهر
في الصوره مراسم استقبال الرئيس الصيني
[موسيقى]
اذا اذا كما ذكرنا هذه الصور للرئيس
الصيني الذي وصل الى موسكو في
اجتماعات مهمه ستعقد بحسب ما تحدث الينا
مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل تتناول في البدايه
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين وايضا
يغيب عنها ملف الحرب حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وكذلك ما يتعلق بالتبادل التجاري
بين البلدين وايضا ما يتعلق بالتعاون في
مجالات عديده منها ايضا
التعاون العسكري بين البلدين وكنا قد
ذكرنا بانه استبق الرئيس الصيني هذه
الزياره بمقال نشر في الصحف الروسيه وايضا
في الصحف الصينيه وتحدث فيه عن علاقات
البلدين التاريخيه وايضا عن الاوضاع
الدوليه بما فيها كما ذكرنا الحرب في
اوكرانيا
بطبيعه الحال الكريم قال ان بوتين
سيتطرقان الى موضوع مبادره السلام الصينيه
وكان قد اقترحها الرئيس الصيني وان تكون
عبر الحوار طريقا للخروج من الازمه
[موسيقى]